وقال جون كيربي منسق السياسات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي ان هدف واشنطن ليس احتواء
الحوثيين وانما وقف الهجمات على سفن الشحن
التجاري حسب قوله واوضح ان واشنطن ستستمر
في التنسيق مع حلفائها وشركائها بشان
الخطوات التي ستتخذها اذا استمرت الهجمات
في البحر
الاحمر الولايات المتحده لا تسعى الى
الصراع ريد مرورا امنا للتجاره العالميه
عبر البحر الاحمر وسوف نستمر في التنسيق
والتشاور مع حلفائنا وشركائنا بشان
الخطوات المناسبه التي سنتخذها لاحقا اذا
استمرت هذه الهجمات
من واشنطن ينضم الينا الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه دكتور خليل مرحبا بك ما هي هذه
الخطوات وما هي اصلا الخيارات المتاحه
امام
الامريكيين والغرب عموما لمواجهه ما يحصل
في البحر
الاحمر يعني على ما يبدو حسن هناك قرار
يعني شبه متخذ من قبل امريكا وحلفائها
فيما يسمى بائتلاف حراس الازدهار الذي
تشكل قبل حوالي اقل من شهر من الان في 19
ديسمبر الماضي باتخاذ خطوات ليس فقط
وقائيه وانما ايضا هجوميه نحن اذاء تصاعد
واضح جدا لدائره الصراع في منطقه البحر
الاحمر هناك اليوم او بالامس هجوم معقد
جدا نتكلم على هجوم بحوالي 21 مسيره
وصواريخ كروز و صواريخ بالستيه تم تصدي
لها من خلال حملات الطيارات الامريكيه
الموجوده هناك ايزنهاور وكذلك سفن او
مدمرات بحريه امريكيه وبريطانيه بنتكلم
على هذا هو الهجوم رقم 26 في اقل من 50
يوم فبنت هجوم كل يومين تقريبا فبنت على
يعني حرب ولكنها حرب ضيقه ضيقه او قليله
المستوى بشكل او باخر يعني لو انتنستي وور
كما تسمى في العلاقات الدوليه فبنت لم على
على ما يبدو هناك خطط امريكيه بالقيام
بعمليات نوعيه ضد الحوثيين وكما قال كربي
قبل قليل الهدف ليس هو الاحتواء هذهه
الهجمات بل وقفها بشكل او باخر والوقف هنا
يعني وضع خطط لمهاجمه الحوثيين في عقر
دارهم في اليمن ولكن ما الذي يضمن هنا
للامريكيين ان تكون الخطوات الهجوميه التي
تتحدث
عنها ان لا تؤدي الى توسع الصير والدخول
في صراع وهو ما تسعى او تعلن واشنطن انها
تسعى الى
منعه ليس هناك اي ضمن على اطلاق حسن بل
بالعكس هي تفعل كل ما يؤدي الى اتساع نطاق
الصراع وقلنا اكثر من مره المشكله
الرئيسيه لست موجوده في البحر الاحمر هي
موجوده هناك في قطاع غزه موجوده بالاساس
في الدعم الامريكي العسكري والدبلوماسي
والسياسي غير المحدود لاسرائيل موجوده في
عدم الدعوه لوقف اطلاق النار وبالتالي هي
تعالج العرض وليس المرض نحن اذاء ازمه
موجوده على مدار ثلاث شهور في قطاع غزه
دعم امريكي غير محدود يدفع الاطراف
المنخرط في هذا الصراع الى القيام بهجمات
راينا اليوم ايضا هجمات معقده على قواعد
عسكريه موجوده قرب اربيل في كردستان
وهجمات ايضا في جنوب لبنان وبالتالي كل ما
تقوله امريكا عن عدم اتساع منطق الحرب
تفعل ضده تماما يعني مثلا فيما يتعلق
بالبحر الاحمر من المعروف ومن ناحيه
الاعراف الدوليه والتقليد الدوليه اي صراع
في الممرات المائيه يجب ان يحل من خلال
التفاهم من خلال ما يطلق عليه كوليكتيف
سكيورتي او الامن الجماعي نحن اذاء منطق
امريكي يقوم على فرض القوه والبلطجه
والعسكر البحر الاحمر هناك حاله تعبئه غير
مفهومه حتى ما يسمى باتلاف الازدهار هو
ائتلاف يعني يعتبر ائتلاف غير شرعي لماذا
لانه لم يحظى باي قرار من مجلس الامن ليس
هناك مديت او تفويض مجلس الامن بهذا
الائتلاف هذا ائتلاف يقوم على حمايه مصالح
امريكا في المنطقه العربيه حمايه مرات
الملاحه العالميه والدوليه خاصه في منطقه
الحيويه جدا وكنا اكثر من مره منطقه تضم
على الاقل ثلاث مساحات مائيه مهمه جدا
البحر الاحمر خليج عدن المحيط الهندي
وكذلك الخليج العربي قناه السويس باب
المندب وهرمز وبالتالي منطقه حيويه تماما
اي حل لمشاكل لن يتم عن طريق القوه بل عن
طريق التفاوض وهنا نقطه مهمه جدا حسن
الطرف الحضر الغائب هنا هو ايران ليس هناك
تفاوض او اتفاق او محادثات مع ايران من
اجل حل هذه الازمه
السؤال ماذا لو اتسعت دائره الصراع اذا
اتخذت الولايات المتحده تلك الخطوات
الهجوميه وماذا تستفيد الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا اذا ما اتسعت بشكل اكبر و يعني
اصبح الهدف كل السفن وليس فقط السفن التي
يقول الحوثيون انها لها علاقه باسرائيل
بطريقه او
باخرى بالنسبه للخطوات اتوقع القيام بضرب
نوعيه على القدرات العسكريه لحركه
الحوثيين سواء بنتكلم على يعني استخدام
طيرات مسيره استخدام صواريخ من البحر
باتجاه بعض القاعده العسكريه للحوثيين
وطبعا ليس هناك اي ضمان بنجاحها فيما
يتعلق بالاهداف كما قلت هناك تناقض
وازدواجيه امريكيه في الوقت الذي تقول فيه
امريكا انها لا تسعى لاتساع نطاق الحرب هي
تقوم بكل ما هو عكس ذلك تقوم بعمليه تحش
تعبئه وتحشيد في الخليج العربي او في
البحر الاحمر تقوم بعمليات دعم مستمره كما
قلت لاسرائيل وكما قلنا اكثر من مره
المشكله لس في البحر الاحمر المشكله ان
هناك دعما امريكيا غير محدودا لاسرائيل
وبالتالي هذا جزء طبيع زي ما يطلق عليه
يعني كولاترل دمج او هذا يعتبر نوع من
تداعيات الصراع الصراع الاصلي موجود ان
هناك عدم اكتراث امريكي بما يحدث في قطاع
غزه هناك ارتفاع مستمر لضحايا المدنيين بل
ان جوله بلينكن حتى جوله فشله على كل
المستويات لم ينجح في اي هدف من اهدافها
سواء الهدف المتعلق بتخفيض العمليات
العسكريه المتعلق باطلاق سراح الرهائن
متعلق بعد مساع نطاق الحرب المتعلق باليوم
الال للحرب هناك فشل ذريع لهذه الجوله
وبالتالي هناك استمار للصراع ب اتساع ل
نطاقه سواء في البحر الاحمر او في لبنان
او في العراق او حتى في سوريا